foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
liar liar pants on fire Rue Giuliani
admits what we all know
[Music]
she's lying about Ruby Freeman and her
daughter sheamos of course of course he
was we've known this for a long time
that Rudy Giuliani was defaming her
he was lying about there
their attempt to steal the election
Donald Trump in Georgia we knew that was
all a [__] lie
it's not it's not news is it really oh
yes there is news about Rudy's lies Rudy
has now admitted that he lied
he admitted
that he lied
oh boy uh oh
so what does that mean in the defamation
suit well it doesn't put it to bed yet
my guess is my guess is is this and I'm
gonna get to the hunter Biden thing I
know the hunter Biden stuff is breaking
and the right wing is just foaming at
the mouth over this I'm gonna get to it
don't worry I'll get to the hunter by
news in just a second
but Rudy Giuliani my guess is is that
Rudy is flipped
with Jack Smith
and this is an indication that Rudy has
flipped with Jack Smith and the reason
why I say that is because
to to actually be on the side of the
prosecutor a couple things have to
happen
Rudy's gonna have to give good evidence
to the prosecutors in D.C that yeah
I I'm a potential informant and I will
act in good faith and still continuing
on this defamation suit where he keeps
saying I didn't lie I didn't lie I
didn't lie
it's not in good faith the other thing
that could be possible is the judge in
the case of the defamation of Ruby
Freeman and her daughter sheamos is that
Rudy Giuliani refuses or keeps stalling
to hand over Discovery and documents and
it's possible that that discovering
documents is part of another criminal
case wink Jack Smith
and that could be the the tightrope that
Rudy is walking here if you can imagine
Rudy Giuliani
walking a tightrope I don't know if
that's even uh in in the imagination of
anybody maybe in a cartoon uh but
Rudy Giuliani it does seem that he has
flipped here
um in in in the DC January 6 coup
attempt case against Donald Trump it
does seem that Donald Trump
um knows that this is going to come to a
head because he's been posting about how
he's going to take the stand
he's going to take the stand at the
trial good do it Grandpa do it I dare
you
can you I I think I said this several
months ago can you imagine
can you imagine the great the great
theater The Great American history that
would be made
if Jack Smith
if Jack Smith was able
two question Donald Trump under oath in
open court oh my God
please inject that into my veins now
right now inject that into my veins
that's what I want
he won't he won't take the stand I mean
he's dumb but he ain't that stupid is he
I mean maybe he is maybe we will get
that piece of American History we'll
absolutely [__] destroy himself in
open court when Jack Smith is
questioning him
now we won't I don't think we'll have
video evidence of it because it's
unlikely that a federal judge would ever
allow a video camera inside of a
courtroom but we would have transcripts
we would have sketch artists sketching
it and maybe a movie
I don't know if we get off strike if sag
and the Raiders get off strike we might
have a [__] movie on our hands don't
you think
oh I laugh about it but it's a serious
issue they did try to overthrow our
government
they try and John Eastman even yesterday
John Eastman's attorneys uh sending a a
memo a letter a motion to the
prosecutors begging them not to indict
him begging them not to indict him only
an indication that John Eastman knows
he's going to get indicted here and the
reason why is because of the target
letter to Trump
John Eastman knows knows he's a Target I
don't know that John Eastman has
actually uh testified in front of the
grand jury which makes him a huge Target
I don't know if you know that
when someone testifies in front of the
grand jury they can be a Target but
they're not necessarily the target
right
you know that
so
if you're being interviewed by the grand
jury in the cool case the January 6
violent Insurrection the the attempt to
overthrow our government and make Donald
Trump the dictator and King of the
United States of America
if that's if you're not called in to the
grand jury to testify in front of them
you're probably in big [__] trouble
I'm just saying
you're probably in big ass trouble if
you haven't been called into the grand
jury you're likely a Target
now it doesn't mean that someone who
testifies in front of a grand jury isn't
also a Target or can't cut can't catch a
case right in the case of Ruby Giuliani
it is possible
but it is less likely when you testify
in front of a grand jury
that you are going to receive some sort
of deal even if you do catch a case
why do you think um it is so it is so
imperative that cribs
a member of the homeland security team
who briefed Donald Trump before the
election
that you can't there's no and there's no
national election fraud dummy
our elections aren't centralized I don't
know if people you know that's one thing
that gets missed in this whole goddamn
thing that's why they went out you know
that's why they went after dominion and
smartmatic right
because Dominion smart manic have a huge
market share of the voting machines
but that still doesn't mean that the
elections are centralized
we do not have a national centralized
election you know that right States run
elections
and the county election offices are the
ones who hold them
in this country the local election
officials are the ones responsible for
holding those elections
and the state the state is the one
who has the law there are federal
election laws but the states are the
ones who run the election I don't know
if you know that I didn't know if you
knew that how the electors get certified
huh I I did you know that a governor
holy [__] a governor has to certify him
too huh what what part of government is
the can someone look up for me if a
governor is over a state or the federal
government look that up for me of course
we know the answer
of course we know the answer that's why
this is really stupid
that cribs had to go to Trump and
explain this to him
that you can't have election fraud on a
national scale a centralized type of
election fraud that's not how our
elections work anyways that's not the
infrastructure of our elections that's
one reason why we shouldn't have
National centralized elections
it's one reason why fake democracies
have National centralized elections so
they can rig them
you see do you see do you see it
is is there things that we need to look
at in our election system absolutely we
can look at them and make them better
early voting could be a hell of a lot
better
we could actually Force these states to
put drop boxes in more spots so people
can drop their ballot mail-in ballots
should be more available
early ballots should be more available
to folks in this country
it works it works
everyone should have to opt out of their
registration not opt-in
there's things that can be changed on a
local state and federal level
absolutely voting rights is a key is a
key key part of our democracy
but the idea the idea that there was
somehow the the centralization of
Elections is [__] boneheaded at best
and Cribs the one who briefed Donald
Trump so it only is evidence that Donald
Trump knew even before the election
that the election is not centralized you
cannot rig an election nationally that
is not how the infrastructure works
that it would require that all Democrats
and Republicans in charge of the
election would have to look
be in lockstep
and that's just asinine that's
ridiculous to even think that that could
happen
with all the counties all the districts
Jesus Christ all the polling stations
all the states get me a [__] break
now
cribs went and testified in front of
Jack Smith grand jury
likely to the point that hey I I told
him that it can't be rigged I gave him
the evidence from Homeland Security
and he still kept believing the pillow
guy
and the Kraken lady
and the guy who Rudy Grandpa farty
mcsharty Rudy Giuliani
with [__] dripping from his temples
that's right that's who he was listening
to and the Overstock guy
that's who he was listening to and
Michael Flynn give me a [__] break
the idea that Donald Trump didn't know
that this election was free and fair
is ridiculous on its face and Jack Smith
is only collecting up the evidence
now we're wait we're on indictment watch
we're on indictment watch for Donald
Trump
aren't we and we're on impeachment watch
for Joe Biden oh my God these House
Republicans and Kevin McCarthy this is
hilarious they're gonna impeach Hunter
Biden
I'm not cheating you they're going to
impeach Hunter by they're gonna do it
that's what these who are we're gonna
we're gonna impeach owner back I mean
Joe Budden 100 but maybe Hunter I don't
know can we impeach Hunter and that gets
rid of Joe badden
even Fox News
even Ducey on Fox News is like how how
the [__] are you gonna you don't even
have any evidence you haven't presented
us of what the evidence is of your what
is impeachable other than Hunter Biden
is a crackhead that's what you're going
to impeach the president for is that
Hunter Biden is a crackhead speaking of
Hunter Biden there's Hunter Biden news
the the plea deal for Hunter Biden fell
apart this morning which
uh is not actually that surprising
seeing what happened the the quick that
I had to catch I've been busy this
morning but I caught the quick back and
forth of why the judge said No Deal and
and Hunter bidenstein said No Deal
and the reason why is because the
prosecution wouldn't leave Farah off the
table
uh basically the deal did not cover that
Hunter Biden could be prosecuted as a
foreign registered agent
and the judge said well you how are you
going to do that how can you how can you
do this with the tax thing and not give
him
uh the the good faith of the foreign
registered agent
and the prosecutor said we're not and
basically Hunter Biden said Team said
well if that's the case no deal and the
judge said No Deal so the deal did fall
apart this morning
which some are saying is bad politically
for Hunter
what bad politically for Hunter what the
[__] are you talking about
Hunter Biden is not the president of the
United States Hunter Biden does not hold
the government position Jesus Christ no
one is lining up around the block to pay
200 to give a donation to The Biden
family for their legal fees to take a
picture with Hunter they are doing that
with Trump they literally paid money to
take pictures with Donald Trump Jr
so that that grandpa has his legal fee
money
you people are [__] insane you're
insane
now this morning it is history
it is history that a child a grown adult
child I don't understand why he has to
be the kid of the president the dude's a
grown ass man
yes is Hunter Biden you know does he lie
has in the passes he like drugs and
prostitutes sure
absolutely there's a lot of people in
their past that have like drugs and
prostitutes hell there's a lot of
people's future that is that is mired in
drugs and prostitutes to be quite honest
with you
it only makes him cool like rock and
roll tight cool but
they see it as impeachable what what the
[__] are you talking about
oh well Joe Biden just may may ever see
bribes because Hunter Biden does drugs
what what the [__] are you talking about
man
get over that his hog is bigger than
yours little bitty penis get over it
it's okay it's just it happens sometimes
some guys wieners is bigger than yours
it's not a big deal really everything is
in a dick measuring contest it isn't or
it doesn't have to be let's say that
Jesus Christ
the [__] are you talking about and just
because this energy falls apart doesn't
mean it's bad politically don't believe
that [__] for a second it's starting to
go around [__] Twitter because the
right wing is gonna seize on this see oh
my god look he is a criminal because
he's trying to get immunity well yeah
he's gonna try to get the best deal he
can and the reason why is the two
charges of taxes
that that he's being charged with the
misdemeanors he paid those taxes
he paid him
and he shouldn't honestly my my view of
it is he shouldn't have to [__] plead
guilty if he's already paid him [__]
them
good for Hunter tell them they [__]
themselves and you know what this throws
a big huge wrench
and the Republicans little idea that
this prosecutor is somehow the Deep
State doesn't it
doesn't it for the last for the last
three four [__] weeks that's all
we've heard is how Weiss is in the
pocket of the deep state or some stupid
[__] that somehow they conspired with
the Biden Administration to give him
some sort of a deal when the deal fell
apart
it only crashes their narrative that's
it it only smashes up their [__]
lies that's all this does this morning
that's it because the truth is is that
is that Hunter Biden wanted didn't want
a [__] cop felony charges yes
absolutely who the [__] would
who the [__] would
you wanna would you want to go down for
Grandpa poopy pants he definitely
doesn't want [__] felony chart I mean
he's got enough of them
he's got enough of them already you
won't want any more [__] any more
felony charges
but here we are sitting here and we
we're gonna have to listen how now now
the prosecutors aren't the Deep state
now they've come to their senses or some
stupid [__] that's gonna be the right
wing narrative it's going to be the
exact opposite of what they've been
saying the last three or four [__]
weeks you know he's not going to change
their tune people who don't give a [__]
about Hunter Biden
I don't give I'm never gonna vote for
Hunter Biden you stupid [__]
I guarantee you every single audience
member here will never have the chance
to vote for Hunter Biden because Hunter
Biden's never going to be on a [__]
ballot
you dumb sons of [__]
and you know what you know what I think
here's what I think now that the deal is
done what I think Hunter Biden should do
is Hunter Biden should go ahead and run
for president I'm dead serious
I'm dead serious Hunter Biden should go
ahead and announce that he's going to
run for president he's going to run
against his father and Donald Trump why
not I mean I the case should be the case
should be that Hunter Biden Hunter
Biden's running for president you can't
prosecute him right you can't prosecute
someone who's running for president
if you're a viable and man they really
do think they really do think
that Hunter Biden is running for
president so if he actually ran for
president well then [__]
nah [__] then well why not
maybe maybe just maybe maybe just maybe
Hunter Biden can seek can seek some kind
of election immunity that's what Grandpa
Poopypants seems to believe
that just because you're running for
president means that they can't charge
you they can't try you
hmm
it's so stupid
it's so [__] dumb it's dumb it's dog
[__] but this is the [__] timeline
that we live in because these brain dead
idiots are cultists
they're members of the Trump cult James
Comer Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan
it's all part of the [__] Trump cult
and to protect Trump from his his
misdeeds always every [__] last bit
of it even Kevin Kevin McCarthy this
morning Kevin McCarthy this morning
talking more about impeachment inquiries
based on what impeachment of who Hunter
Biden again maybe Hunter should [__]
run
maybe he should [__] run
[__] RFK Jr RFK Jr wouldn't stand a
chance
against Hunter Biden
[Laughter]
no it's so stupid it's so [__] dumb
but it shouldn't be surprising that with
this with the nincompoop Nazis that we
have Hitler would be so disappointed in
these people
he really would he said Hitler's such a
[__] scumbag and such a scab on our
world history what a what a bile piece
of trash Hitler was but even he would be
disappointed in these nincompoop Nazis
wouldn't he be Jesus Christ they can't
even get their [__] together they don't
even know who the real enemy is they
don't even know who we're really
impeaching Jesus Christ
yeah
I don't think Jim comer or Jim I don't
report sex crime Jordan would ever last
in the SS at all not a minute
my God
ah
I I even feel like my commentary gets
Dumber because of them right
I would much rather move on to something
more important like bionomics
like the economy I don't know like
trying to make sure that everyone
doesn't go broke because of a medical
bill in this country making sure that
parents have the opportunity to send
their children to school at three
instead of five understanding that the
American people should be able to seek
higher education without having to pay
their entire lives back to the school
that they went to
that that the American people could
afford housing that they can own and be
their own the American dream that they
[__] tell us about
the freedom and liberty that we're
supposed to have and the great
opportunity that this country affords us
[__] most people can't even afford a
goddamn house
it's ridiculous you can't even get a
decent [__] wage today
unless unless you're in a union and
they're willing to fight speaking of
that there's more news and unions the
SAG and the writers strike still
continues there's no end in sight
as the studios
working out with the actors and the
writers but the UPS the UPS strike is
avoided
the ups and the media is so stupid Oh my
God
I was listening to the media this
morning report this UPS strike thing is
avoided they're like oh this is great
for Biden because now the strike won't
affect the economy you [__] you
[__] it's good for the workers
what the [__] are you talking about it's
good for the workers the full-time
workers went from 45 to 49 an hour the
full-time drivers the part-time drivers
went from like 13 or some stupid [__] up
to 21.
up to 21.
dollars an hour now that's only
part-time and they probably are worth a
lot more than 21.49 dollars
but they showed what what labor can
organize labor can do they can look at a
corporation and say [__] you we want
ours you get yours we want ours the only
reason why you exist is us [__]
that's it you wouldn't exist without us
and we'll show you with a strike
and they came to the table and they did
a deal
and they did a deal
so it's and and this this the media is
spinning this as if this was going to be
a disaster for Biden this was not going
to be a disaster for Biden this was
going to be a disaster for corporations
who rely on their labor
that's what it was going to show is that
if you don't have your [__] labor you
don't have a business
UPS can't operate without [__] having
labor nor should they in this country we
should never afford UBS the right to
operate without labor [__] them the same
way as the writers and sag is right that
you shouldn't be able to operate without
humans [__] you [__] you we don't even
care if it's possible with technology
you shouldn't be able to do it
but the media spinning this is if this
is some sort of win for that for the
corporations and and the economy and
Biden [__] this is a win for the
workers and this is a win for workers
everywhere it should be a sounding
message to workers everywhere that you
should [__] unionize you should
gather up and organize against
corporations for your [__] labor you
should negotiate your goddamn labor
that's all this country has to trade
mostly
I think we came to that conclusion after
the pandemic
that yeah corporations and Venture
capitalists and the rich people in this
world in this country they have all the
money in the world to trade
they got all kinds of capital to trade
the only Capital that the American
people the average working middle class
American and lower class American has to
trade is their labor
that's our capital
don't you see it don't you see and we
should get paid for that capital for
what it's worth
and that's what UPS did that's what sag
and the writers are doing
that's what they're doing it's a win for
all workers everywhere and anyone who
says different is a [__] bonehead
is even if you're not a union worker and
you're not a union card carrier
you should be excited that UPS did this
deal you should be excited when the
studios reach a deal with sag and the
writers Union
you should be [__] happy if you're a
worker
and the reason why is because it only
shows this country that yes yes the
American people
the American people deserve a decent
[__] wage for the labor that they
trade
why is it so hard
why is it so hard to say that why is it
so hard to spend that narrative
you got to get mired in the actual the
the [__] minimum wage number [__]
that [__] you don't have to get mired in
that argument the hell with that
try and watch someone debate that people
shouldn't get paid what they're worth
good luck to you [__] like Bob
Iger
Bob iger's popularity [__] tanked in
this country didn't it
and the reason why is because he
absolutely he absolutely
[__] on the workers apparently there's
breaking news The Plea deals back on
with Hunter
ah God I don't know why I don't know how
oh but the [__] right wing probably
stepped in it again
oh man this is what happens when you
your entire Foundation of your narrative
and your political commentary is [__]
lies
his [__] lies
but that's the way it goes with the
Republican Party they're definitely
gonna throw that rake out there and
[__] jump on it you can guaran damn T
they're gonna throw a rake and jump on
it
listen and I want to go back to the
labor point one last point that I want
to make
and I truly believe before we go to
break here and I truly believe this is
that
labor in this country and labor strikes
in this country is what will kill
trumpism
yes I said it
labor strikes in this country will kill
trumpism
because Republicans if we can get them
in this fight to fight against the
strikes because they will oh my God
there is nothing more than [__]
Republican scumbags like better than
[__] on workers
you goddamn right catboyism
catboy is the best free market
what do you think what do you think
people organizing to negotiate their
labor to trade in the free market is
other than free market capitalism you
dumb [__]
that is a fight that is a fight that
would kill trumpism you know that right
the fight the fight for workers in this
country in the fight for a decent
[__] wage and for all people not just
union members but all people to get a
decent [__] wage
will kill
trumpism
murder it
slay it at its core
absolutely 100 percent
fighting for decent wages will murder it
there ain't a goddamn Trump supporter
out there
that that is worth their weight and
thought
they still have a couple brain cells to
rub together and I'm not talking about
the cultists I'm talking about the
people who will vote for him
even though they don't like the
[__]
they'll stand they'll stand with decent
wages for people they will it would kill
it at its core
at its core it will kill it that's what
we should do we should keep fighting
just like we fight every single day
right here on the Tony Michaels podcast
every single weekday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube don't
forget to hit the Subscribe button hit
the like down below I'm trying to get
better at this YouTube thing hit the
like button down below that helps us get
into the algorithms you can hit the
dislike button too make sure to comment
make sure to engage I don't know I'm
trying to get by I'm I promise you I'm
trying to get better at this YouTube
thing I'm just
I'm just good at yelling and screaming
about politics not getting you to like
and share I guess I don't know share the
share the that link too to the YouTube
page every single weekday you can also
go follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod here's the news the news is and I'd
love to tell you that this is good news
but it may not be good news to some of
you we will not have a show on Friday we
I I am out Gabe is out we can't get the
show on Friday so here's what we're
gonna do with bonehead of the week I'm
not going to deprive you a bone net of
the week I promise we're gonna put the
poll up tonight that's right tonight
bonehead of the week on Wednesday
tomorrow we will do the bonehead episode
tomorrow I apologize that we're not
gonna have a show on Friday that's just
the way it goes that's the way the
cookie crumbles sometimes when it's just
the two of us neither one of us can do
the show on Friday so we're gonna We're
Not Gonna deprive you a bone end of the
week I love bone end of the week so
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it one
day early so tonight will be the poll
for bone end of the week so make sure to
subscribe here on YouTube you can vote
on the community tab on YouTube and also
you can vote on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod tonight for bone end of the week and
we will do bonehead of the week for you
tomorrow
also download every single episode on
Apple Spotify and Google
you gotta listen to the audio version
you gotta listen to it and if you if you
still want to watch it but you don't
like YouTube or maybe you don't like
watching it on Twitter it's [__] to
watch on Twitter Twitter sucks but but
here here's you can watch us on Facebook
at Tony Michaels if you got a Facebook
account you should be following us over
there I'm so close to 2 000 followers I
think it's two thousand or on Facebook
you should go follow me right now if
you're listening to me on Facebook and
you don't follow at Tony V Tony Michaels
go follow right now also follow us on
Twitch
we got a hefty crowd over there on
Twitch now there's a lot of people show
up in the chat on Twitch if you haven't
gotten into the chat on Twitch you
should go over there and check it out
and if you have your Amazon Prime
account linked to your Twitch account
what you should do is you should
re-subscribe every single month
with that one free subscription that you
get with your Amazon Prime account the
Amazon gaming if you need directions all
you have to do is go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com
you will find the directions there to
link your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account and it gives us monetary
support
and it doesn't cost you a single extra
dime because you get one free
subscription on Twitch with your Amazon
Prime account so go link those resub
every single month give us that monetary
support that doesn't cost you a single
extra dime go to the Tony michaels.com
it's the fourth one down it says link
Amazon and twitch
and it'll link those accounts so you can
give us monetary support not costing you
a single extra nickel not one not one
not one extra nickel thanks for joining
us today don't go anywhere uh we're
gonna bring you the news
with the you know
with the f word pampered in don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott finder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
someone in the chat on YouTube is asking
boycott binder question mark yeah
of course it's satire and parody I don't
know maybe we should make them maybe the
right wing would buy those [__]
the same way as the pardon blanket we
could definitely get members of Congress
to buy the pardon blanket a show
Michelle Michelle oh I got more news I
got more news on the hunter Biden thing
yes the deal is back on apparently and
here's an update from Zachary Cohen uh
on CNN and from CNN another update
prosecutors and everybody have now
agreed to a revised plea deals covered
from 2014 to 2019 only includes conduct
related to tax offenses drug use and gun
possession which is the charges that
he's pleading guilty to two sides have
agreed that this does not Shield Hunter
Biden from uh future future potential
charges which to be quite honest oh
that's not working wait a second
get the wrong one up there hang on hang
on let me show it to you oh boy I got
excited I got too excited I guess here
let me show it to you
there it is there it is there's the
update
oh there it is another update again uh
this deal covers 2014 to 2019 and it
covers the charges that he's pleading
guilty to tax offenses drug use and gun
possession uh it says two sides have
agreed that this does not Shield Hunter
Biden from potential future charges uh
oh uh oh remember when I said that this
that don't worry this is not going to be
a bad narrative
and the reason why is because it's
obvious that Hunter Biden is now
pleading guilty to these charges without
having immunity of future investigations
so he's still being or can be
investigated you [__] Tweeds
the right Wingers are gonna step in it
again I guarantee you can find 100
tweets that are going to say the
opposite of what this is true
hear that the two sides have agreed that
this does not Shield undermine potential
future charges
now um I still haven't got word that if
the judge has accepted these and they're
in court now you won't actually be
sentenced today at least I don't think
he will be uh there there will be a
different magistrate that'll actually
sentence him and this just this judge in
federal court just accepts his plea deal
and then later on it will actually be
can he'll be sentenced to or whatever
um the judge that sent in his sentencing
judge will give him and so
so it's going to be a lot of [__]
from the right wing today
it's gonna be a lot of [__] but you
know that's how it goes with the right
wing it's going to be complete utter uh
nonsense but let's go let's go uh first
to the Rudy Giuliani story because I
think that's the better story here
[Music]
I I thought I had I thought I had it
here
not that Senator Biden oh here here's
Rudy okay I want to show you this to you
and here's here's RI Giuliani why the
[__] is that
man why is that like that that's [__]
weird okay well we'll roll with it
here's the here's Rudy Giuliani
apparently here lately and I'm talking
about
um
Joe Biden that's let me back it up let's
go whole world knows that our president
is a criminal
and uh it is it is making not just the
Bible administration of corrupt it's
making America look corrupt it's Way
Beyond time for a patient the man should
not be a criminal should not be in the
white house now I mean to get Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt or I've never seen more
evidence to you I've never seen more
evidence
that a man committed a crime than this
and you could talk about about 31
million dollars
hangovers
hang on a second are you talking about
are you talking about Joe Biden are you
are you talking about Donald Trump
because uh it feels like you're talking
about Donald Trump doesn't it feel like
that it feels like he's thinking about
Jerome doesn't it
I I mean to me it just feels like this
what a [__] idiot
are you kidding me so Rudy Giuliani
admits because he's being sued in
Georgia for defamation uh or from well
uh Ruby Freeman and her daughter shame
ass and we've seen them in the January
6th select hearings and testify to to
Really defaming them and to Trump allies
trying to intimidate them because
somehow they believed somehow they
believe that oh oh this person were
passing Tic Tacs back and forth to each
other so that must have been election
fraud literally that's the evidence that
they were going off of is there were
videos of them passing breathments to
each other and they thought that was
election fraud somehow somehow passing
breath mints to each other
uh was Ruby Freeman and Sheamus stealing
the election
it's really ridiculous wild stuff but
you know these [__] cultists will
believe anything that Rudy Giuliani and
Donald Trump puke up
right
I mean that's the case but Rudy Giuliani
here has admitted that he lied I see in
the media spends it too they're like oh
he made he he made false statements
false statement [__] lied he's a liar
he's a lying sack of [__] is what he is
he's a liar now Rudy Giuliani is also um
even though he's admitting that he lied
about those things because that's what
he's admitting that he do he lied I
don't care how he frames it in his
statement he's also saying that he's
protected under his first amendment to
lie that's basically what he's that's
his defense for this defamation now I
believe two things could be happening
here number one Rudy Giuliani Rudy
Giuliani knows that he's going to
[__] lose that case
um so maybe this is his attempt to get a
settlement out of court but more than
likely than anything because this judge
was asking for more discovery that Rudy
was not willing to hand over that that
Discovery points out crimes
that Discovery points out crimes
and he knows he can't handle over that
Discovery because it points out crimes
and it may be it could be two different
um fork in the road here type thing one
reason why Rudy can't hand over this
discovery that would point out his
crimes and election fraud actually
election fraud for him
is because he doesn't want to catch a
case but it also could be because he's
already caught a case
in Georgia
and also he's catching a case in DC and
what he's trying to do is he's trying to
cooperate and one of the cooperation
points is to admit that he lied and get
rid of this defamation suit so that he
doesn't have to provide discovery
because that's what he's trying to stop
he's not trying to stop the case he's
trying to stop the discovery and the
judge wanted more discovery on how this
[__] was lying
that's the key
and when he when they're doing that when
they're doing that okay he wanted to
make sure that the discovery didn't get
out there in the open
which it could be a lot of different
reasons why he didn't want to get this
[__] out in the open but he still goes
on Trader TV news networks like Bannon
show like all the other she has his own
[__] Trader TV News Network show
where he's just spewing lies and they
get to do that that's the crazy part now
it can be used against him in the court
of law
but they can still lie it does you can't
stop them from lying out in the open
it's not a thing and and really honestly
this is the thing that the Democrats in
the left gets wrong all the time
they want to stop people from doing this
you can't stop someone from lying you
can't you can't stop it especially
scumbags like this
scumbags like this are always gonna lie
there's nothing you can do about it not
a goddamn thing I mean you can prosecute
them for their crimes and you can use
their lies against them
because anything you say can be held
against you in the court of law I mean
most of these people have the right to
remain silent but don't have the [__]
ability
like Rudy Giuliani and Donald Trump they
just don't have the ability
but folks the thing is is we have to out
loud them right we have to drown out
their lives with our truth that's the
thing that's what we have to do
you can't work your whole life to censor
them
when it will censor you you have to tell
the [__] truth loud and proud and
keep going and keep pounding that drum
why do you think I show up here every
single weekday
pounding the drum for two hours yelling
and screaming into this microphone
giving you the ability to use your own
microphones and go out there and do and
engage in your democracy speaking of
engaging democracy we had a great
um we're calling it Roundtable of
democracy yesterday you know I was
ranting on the show
and I was talking about phone a bonehead
and I was gonna go with Tommy tuberville
at first but then I got so pissed off at
the Texas Republicans that I was like
[__] it we're gonna do a phone the
bonehead we're just gonna do it we're
gonna do this democracy Roundtable on
the patreon and it was a success and I
don't know if you know this but the
video is up Live on YouTube that's right
it's up live right now on YouTube you
guys can go watch yesterday's democracy
Roundtable what we did it's not a rant
like this it's not typical Tony
Michael's content so if you don't if you
don't if you don't if you want the
cathartic release come here for the show
but this all's I did was just kind of
give a tour of the fivecalls.org website
where it shows you the scripts that
shows you how to find the scripts to
call your representatives you can enter
your your your location in it'll give
you all your representatives
it was it was great so many people loved
it and a lot of people sent me messages
saying hey I've already made a phone
call I've already made a phone call I
already looked up all my reps this is
great I've already went through all the
information about all the topics that
are on five calls it worked out
fantastic and we're gonna keep doing it
we're gonna keep doing the round table
where we get together in a workshop and
talk to each other and we're going to do
it on patreon so it's a small group but
I'm going to make it available to
everyone
once we get the content together then we
will produce it for you and then we'll
release it to the public because the
patreon members you guys in the audience
have so many ideas so many ideas uh
Diane said explain so here's what we're
doing we're doing a round table of
democracy on my patreon page and it's
just a simple thing where we all get
together and we try to learn the tools
to engage in our democracy because I say
so many times on the show engage in your
democracy engage in your democracy but I
don't give you the tools on the show I
don't have enough time to give you tools
on the show so what we're going to do I
thought we would do it on my patreon I
would we would go find those tools and
we would develop them together how to
get them together we would have guests
on I actually I talked to Jess Piper and
hopefully we're gonna have we're going
to have one on education and how to
pressure elected officials on education
in your state about education and laws
whether it be the elected officials or
the school board elected officials
that's right we're gonna have and she's
gonna teach you she's going to show you
the things that she knows about
education and how to engage with those
elected officials whether it be
Republicans Or democrats on the round
table of democracy that's what we're
calling it right now and we're and we're
going to do it on patreon but don't
worry don't worry if you're not a member
if you want to come participate in the
development of it come be a member of
patreon just go to patreon.com Michaels
it's five dollars to join patreon you
can give more you can get into a higher
tier but you're not going to have to be
on patreon to see it after the fact
because we're all going to develop it
together
so we'll have a guest on like Jess
she'll be talking about how to do these
things people ask her questions and then
when they when we get done I'm gonna
post it on YouTube live so you guys will
get to see it I'm gonna make it
available to the public why not I mean
these are tools to engage in your
democracy I want everyone to have them
but we're going to develop it and use
patreon to kind of set the tone
so if you want to participate in the
making of the content and and we're
going to tab meetings on it on what kind
of stuff you want so if you want to join
in if you want to see topics that you
want to and you want to engage in that
way on the patreon go to patreon.com D
Tony Michaels join us there but you're
still going to see what we're going to
produce out of the patreon so it's a
great way for you to get the tools at
hand and we're going to do I'm hoping to
do two or three of these a month
just just keep doing them that way we
have all these tools at someone's
disposal because so many times people
don't really know how they want to
engage in their democracy right
they have no clue how they want to
engage I engage every single day by
yelling into the microphone that's how I
do it right and I figured I could use my
platform and my influence to bring you
the tools so you could find the tools
that you want
because you find finding the tools that
you want whether it be registering
voters rather it be sending text
messages or emails some people want to
write letters some people want to write
postcards
some people want to make those phone
calls every single week to the
representatives to tell them how they
feel about these issues right to get it
on the record with their officials and
why it's so important to do that
and why we need to engage on every
single one of these topics right that's
what I think the Roundtable democracy
will do is here on the Tony Michaels
podcast I will give you the cathartic
release I will I will give you why you
need to engage why you need to engage
on the Roundtable democracy will how you
can engage and find those tools because
we're not going to develop a lot of
tools ourselves we're there's a lot of
stuff that exists out there that you
just don't know about and we're going to
seek it out we're going to find it we're
going to show you how to use it and if
you decide hey that's how I want to
engage boom you got it now you got the
tool to go out and engage in your
democracy the way that you want to
engage because that's the most important
part you don't have to engage in every
single part you just have to find the
way that you want to engage and do that
that's the important thing so I think
it's going to be great it was it was a
great it was a great little tour it was
a great first one-off that we did on the
patreon so if you're interested in
developing the content and having say in
the content come to patreon.com see Tony
Michaels join there it's five ten twenty
dollars any tier will get you in uh the
[__] bam is not it's not picky over
there we're all in it together we're all
in this together we all want to help
each other that's the point of it so
come join us over there there but if you
if you can't afford it no problem no
problem if you can't afford to be on the
patreon it's not a big deal we are going
to release all this to the public so you
can see these things so you can see
these things
it's great so we we will have workshops
continue to have workshops we're going
to invite people in
I actually had contact with the person
who does five calls I'm hoping we can
get them or a team member of theirs to
come tell us about five calls more
because I'm not an expert on five calls
I just showed you the website and how to
navigate through it what's on there we
kind of went through it together
and that way someone who didn't even
know it exists like hey this is kind of
cool and people were already making
phone calls so that's the key that's the
key uh with the Roundtable democracy so
again come join us on patreon.com see
Tony Michaels and more news Gabe's going
to join us about 10 minutes I want as we
get more audience members in here and
people who haven't heard this yet I'm
not going to be here on Friday neither
is Gabe we're trying we tried to work to
have a show on Friday but neither of us
can do the show
so because of that uh you know Friday is
bonehead of the week tonight we're gonna
do bonehead one day early so bone of the
week the poll is going to be tonight
you're gonna be able to vote for bone of
the week you vote you decide to shoot
who is the boner of the week and
tomorrow we're gonna do bonehead of the
week on Thursday show I really apologize
I wish I could have a better excuse
other than I I just can't do the show on
Friday
um I have prior engagements I made plans
gave made plans we just can't cover it
that's what happens when there's two of
us we
kazmo says slankers yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah ah it's
hotter than hell I'm sweating whew holy
moly
it's hot
it's gonna be like 102 degrees this week
in Missouri it's probably gonna feel
like it's a thousand
uh Margie says on on Facebook are we
having a three-hour show on Thursday
well you know with bone of the week we
uh bone of the week
it ends up being it ends up being uh uh
it ends up being longer normally with
bone of the week uh Scott on uh YouTube
says put Rachel on I'm I'm assuming
you're talking about Rachel bidikoff are
you been on Friday
listen I would love to get a guest host
outside me and Gabe
um
but I'm going to tell you a little
secret that maybe most people don't know
it literally is just me behind this when
I yell over here there's not a team of
people over here it's a wall that's a
wall
there's not a team of people over here
it literally is just me running this
show and then Gabe when he comes in it
it is harder than you think behind here
um to to be watching all the news to
have all the things on the screen to
make sure it's delivered in a certain
format and a certain way for you to see
it uh it is a little more difficult so
it would take a little bit to uh
um
it would take a little bit
to just
train someone so uh to do the show like
I do it
oh boy oh boy I'd love to have a guest
host though that'd be kind of cool I
think right
once we get the audience big enough and
we have enough support out there we'll
be able to have other people and come on
and be guest host
we'll be able to because we'll like have
a producer that can do they can do
things
well Damon says Tony yelling at the wall
explains everything yeah it does did you
really think I had people over here
get give me a yes or a no in the chat if
you really thought I had a a whole team
of people over here there is not and
there's no one over there it literally
is just a wall here look here look it's
just a wall it's just a wall there's
nothing over there
I'm literally just yelling into the wall
it's just a bit it's supposed to be
funny I don't know I think it's funny
no no one actually thought that okay so
I didn't trick you that great a ghost
assistant uh Stephan on Twitch says uh
just Gabe you know what this is funny so
I was I had a meeting this morning and
someone said in this meeting that me and
Gabe had great chemistry
and I said yeah it's kind of funny we
have great chemistry uh on the show I
said we've never actually met in real
life and they're like what I'm like no
I've never I've never met the guy in
real life he's never met me in real life
we've never seen each other in real life
only online only on the phone text
message all that on the show here never
in real life have we met and they're
like really I thought you guys were in
the same Studio I'm like no
no no no that's just the way it is
ah digital waterfalls is Tony are you
talking to the background penis I think
they're talking about the dick Shadow
here everyone talks about the dick
Shadow some people said I should get rid
of it but because people like it why
would I get rid of something people like
that didn't make any sense
I want to keep the dick Shadow it'll be
a sad day when the dick channel does
wouldn't it I'm just saying I'm just
saying uh yeah Muhammad Ali is over
there if you remember
um my my studio used to be at this
direction so it used to be face
different I got a bigger desk and bigger
screens so it looks more like like a
like a command center now because I I
need to see a certain amount of things
to do the show and before I had two
smaller screens and it was really hard
to kind of see everything
and do everything that I wanted to do
so I need a bigger screen so I needed a
bigger desk and you know I just wanted a
bigger desk to pile more [__] on top of
it you don't get to see that part you
don't get to see all my garbage on my
desk you just get to see the clean that
clean cone the Kona cleanness right
but uh Muhammad Ali here used to be you
can see it there Muhammad Ali used to be
um on my background all the time because
I was faced a different direction he's
still in the same spot he's still in the
same spot I'm just faced a different
direction if you go watch old shows I
believe was a
how long have I had this desk maybe
about a year no maybe not that long I
don't know I can't remember when I redid
this I put the TV up here so we could
put the the thumbnail on here the Tony
Michaels podcast I used to play the news
back here and people like that's
distracting so I changed that to
but I'm not getting rid of the dick
Shadow we're not getting rid of the dick
Shadow it's not gonna happen it's just
not it's not gonna happen
hey boy oh boy okay let's let's go to
some news how about then stop talking
about Dick Shadows
um
there's a couple there's a hearing going
on oh here's a great one here's uh Eric
swalwell dragging Republicans through
the mud it's always fun to watch Eric
swalwell
um absolutely destroy Republicans so
let's watch it now
Mr secretary you have a serious job
and occasionally you have to deal with
some very unserious Maga colleagues of
mine
your serious job is to secure the Border
of the greatest country in the world a
country that is neighbor to some of the
most violent and economically insecure
countries in the world where people are
willing to risk everything to come here
and somehow you have to secure the
Border but also make sure we're not
pushing little girls back into the river
so they can drown it's a hard job
if it was an easy job we wouldn't have
asked you to do it but you were asked to
do it because you're qualified you're
competent you care you show compassion
and you show up every day
and you deal with this
frankly sir I think sometimes you're too
nice
because if I had a chairman who failed
to honor his own lawful subpoena about
500 days after it was submitted to him
I would say catch me when you're serious
come talk to me when you're going to
follow the law about whether you think I
follow the law
but that's not how you are you take your
job seriously even in front of a lot of
unserious people
in fact the chair that you were sitting
in
you may not know this but the last
person who sat in that chair was called
by the chairman
an anti-vaccine anti-semitic witness in
RFK Jr so you have brought immediate
credibility to the chair that you're
sitting in by just being here
they're not serious people they chide
people for their pronouns
they obsess and display in this
committee and other committees private
citizens non-consensual nude images
we're not talking about serious people
we're not talking about people who are
on the level
and so what do we want to do we want to
acknowledge the seriousness of your job
and hopefully one day in the majority
give you the tools to deliver on what we
believe ultimately can put us in the
most secure place which is comprehensive
immigration reform
oh boy well it shows that Eric swallow
and Democrats are serious about what's
that thing called policy
and all his Republicans can focus on is
Hunter Biden's [__]
it's Insanity it's insanity but it's the
truth I don't know what to tell you
like I said I don't make this [__] up I
don't get to make this [__] up I just
get to come here and comment on what the
hell is going on that's all I do
I I can't I can't force this thing
um let's see that's old Hunter Biden
news I was going to show you a clip of
how the 100 by deal fell apart now it's
back together
oh it feels like it almost it almost
feels like it almost feels like
that that may have been a deep State
ploy to trick them into thinking that
Hunter Biden
wasn't going to take the deal because
he's a foreign and acting foreign agent
oh boy and someone's saying the chat is
hilarious yes the chat is hilarious you
guys talking about the dick Shadow and
everything else you guys get this on
your minds I don't know what to do about
it I don't know if someone brought it up
one time in the Chant that it looks like
there's some people are saying I need to
trim my bush I don't know what to tell
you I don't know I I know you guys like
to have fun you guys like to laugh so
what am I gonna do if you're listen if
you're here for all seriousness like
you're like I don't like that Tony isn't
serious two hours he's not serious the
whole time he cracks jokes he makes
funny voices he does these things he
mocks these people I don't like that
well the Hit the Road Jack
or stick around and be entertained a
little bit grab grab what is important
grab it is irrelevant what is relevant
in the news know what your cathartic
strategic outrage should be towards
these dumb [__] like Eric
swallow just gave us a dose of why you
should be pissed off at these [__]
idiots
they're cheering that children and women
are being drowned in the river instead
of going how can we um how could we get
together I mean I think it's our job is
I don't know lawmakers to set
immigration policy in this country so we
don't I don't know have to drown women
and children in the [__] River
Jesus Christ
and you're mad at me because I mock them
get the [__] out of here you're mad at
me because I crack jokes you're mad at
me that I talk about the dick Shadow
okay all right well keep coming and
hating keep keep at it keep tuning in I
love you too I love you too I don't give
a [__] if you love me or you love to
hate me I love you just keep tuning in
that's all I ask for
you are the greatest audience in the
world you know why because you guys are
the highest highest engaged audience in
the world
what other [__] political show are
you gonna go see where the host is gonna
talk to you the chat about a dick shadow
on the wall huh Can you show it to me
like I said send me that [__] show
I'll go watch it okay
[Laughter]
oh boy speaking of funny
this is hilarious Grandpa poopy pants
this morning's like we'll have fun on
the stand with all these people that say
the presidential election wasn't rigged
and stolen
why is he saying rigged and Stalin
with the capital r and a capital why is
he doing that is his phone set to that
you know what when you type in stuff
long enough your phone's like well that
you must want to say that dumb [__] you
know what I mean I almost bet I almost
bet Donald Trump's [__] iPhone
when he's typing this [__] in it's
guessing the words that he's saying
that's why all these rants sound like
this don't you think
maybe that's what it is maybe when Gabe
gets on here we should ask him this if
that's the case if it's just like
predicting what words he's gonna say
oh my God wouldn't that be great
you know what I mean you just click the
next word to see what the hell is that
called when you click the next word to
see to see what the what what the what
the hell that it'll produce
oh my God but he says he says the
election wasn't rigged and stolen the
trial of the century you goddamn right
dude it's going to be the trial of our
history man
there's never going to be a trial in our
history that's going to be more [__]
important and more of a [__] show than
this one good I hope you take the
[__] Stan you lunatic I really do I I
I I I I want that content don't you
God I hope they let cameras in that
[__] courtroom Jesus Christ how could
you not I mean listen the last episode
in the last season of the Trump show of
the Trump reality dumpster fire yes hell
yeah I mean we've we've went this far
folks in this Trump dumpster fire or
reality TV show why not go all the way
that's all I'm saying why not finish it
off with the money shot of having the
trial televised that's all I'm saying I
mean really honestly why wouldn't we
want to do that
hahaha
oh he's gonna take the stand no you're
not he's not gonna take the stand he's
never done it before he's always
threatened to go to court and take the
stand and all that [__] he's such a
lying sack of [__]
good Lord No One Believes that garbage
just like um
Steve Ducey doesn't believe Republican
House Republicans garbage listen to this
this is Fox News this morning they're
talking about all the evidence that
they're going to use to impeach Hunter
Biden I'm not [__] you
and they want to impeach Hunter I don't
know I I don't know what they're talking
about listen Kevin McCarthy has brought
up the the eyewear the impeachment
question uh and he's calling it an
inquiry this is what he had to say and
the reasons why they're considering this
watch
you've got
eye blower saying something when it
comes to government treating the bidens
different you've got an informant
claiming that the Biden family had been
bride
should you ignore that or you should
investigate that the only way you can
investigate that is through an
impeachment inquiry so the committee
would have the power to get all the
documents that they would need so what
an impeachment inquiry does it gives us
the apex of the power of Commerce for
republicans and Democrats to gather the
information that they need so it's not
an impeachment it is to get all the
information then we're going to inquire
is there is this an impeachable offense
okay look at the graphic that Fox News
even hints on the goddamn look at this
impeachment inquiry with Joe and Hunter
Biden what the [__] are you talking
about man Hunter Biden is not a member
of the government no one voted for
Hunter Biden nobody no one's ever going
to vote for Honor Biden frankly most
people who voted for Joe Biden don't
give a rat's ass about Hunter Biden they
do not give a [__] they do not think
that Hunter Biden his adult son who at
one point in his life was you know kind
of a degenerate I mean he loved [__]
cocaine he loved crack he apparently
loves drugs alcohol and he loved
prostitutes I mean it sounds like a
[__] rock and roll after show to me
the manga should think that he's a
badass and cool
I mean they love Ted Nugent right they
love Kid Rock they love fellatio blow
which sings about all this stuff but oh
Hunter Biden is the enemy yeah okay and
you're gonna impeach Hunter Biden what
the [__] are you talking about well
Steve Ducey is on our side even Steve
doozy's like wait a second here listen
guys we've we've seen this movie a
couple of times before
impeachment inquiry almost always it
leads to an impeachment uh I've heard
from members of Congress on the
Republican side they are going to
they're they're going to do the I word
uh of Joe Biden that guy right there the
I word
what the [__] the I word come on Steve
it's not why how in the [__] did we get
in a position where you gotta say the I
word on Fox news for impeachment now
again this is an impeachment inquiry but
there's no there's if they do an
impeachment acquirer which I doubt they
even [__] do an impeachment acquiry
but the thing is this is the normal
process of a [__] impeachment in the
first place so Gabe Sanchez if you were
going to impeach Hunter Biden you would
want to do impeachment inquiry first
before you actually impeach him that's
what yeah
what I wanna what I want to follow the
rules oh [__] if there's a process or a
protocol in place would I actually
follow those things I don't know man I
I'm telling you what man this whatever
this drama is in court
um for the plea deal of 100 this morning
boy it really is [__] the bed over
there on the right wing side I'm sure I
mean they're probably like yeah
yeah bye and then like oh they accepted
it and he's still under investigation oh
man man yeah maybe maybe it's not the
Deep State maybe it is the Deep State
maybe it's the Matrix like what the [__]
are you people talking about I'm I'm
watching all the responses like oh man
looks like that deal fell apart and it's
like At first I was like oh I guess the
deal fell apart something happened well
it did it did apparently the judge um
from what I understand I haven't seen
the transcripts or anything uh but I was
just following the reporting of people
that were in the in the courtroom
apparently what had happened was is that
the prosecutors the judge asked the
question are the prosecutors going to
basically not charge or investigate
Hunter Biden for pharah which is the
foreign agent uh registration act right
so he he has to register as a foreign
agent properly which we know a lot of
trumpies never did that they didn't do
that Mike Flynn Rudy Giuliani a lot of
them being investigated for pharah but
here's the thing when the judge that the
prosecutors said no no we will not we
will not lay those prosecutions are wide
open right
and Hunter Biden's defense team was like
whoa wait a second no no no no no no no
no you can't go back anything from 14 to
19 is what we understood and the judge
said well do we not have an agreement
and they said well and and Connor might
see me said no in that case we know I'm
in agreement which means in the court
they were confused because because after
they came back he did end up pleading I
I think he's already bled to these
charges the two tax charges from 14 to
19 2014 2019 and the drug and gun chart
that stupid drug and gun charge again
all two a Bros should be really pissed I
I actually think that's a [__]
ridiculous [__] charge I don't think
yeah listen to ATF and the DEA coming
after you man this is the big government
that they talked about if you [__]
think that that the Second Amendment is
uninfringible you should be infuriated
about that [__] charge infuriated
about that charge that you can't do
drugs and have a gun where does it say
in the Second Amendment where does it
say in the Second Amendment only for non
drug use
I think that's appropriate but here's
what I like to mix my cocaine with my
gunpowder wow a lot of manga seems to do
that here's the thing
ah Don Jr isn't a good example yeah
remember the video with Eric greitens oh
you know Eric greens is on something
yeah that guy right in that video there
was a there was a moment where I I felt
like Don Jr was like ah maybe this guy's
a little too crazy for me even Eric
greitens too crazy yeah Donald Trump Jr
but here's the thing with the honor
buying thing is that it was confusion in
the courtroom and they they took a break
so that way they could talk to each
other and they're like oh okay because
what they were confused on was anything
from 2014 to 2019 was the deal well it
is likely it is likely that that Hunter
Biden did not register correctly as a
foreign agent the Republicans want to us
to think that but it is likely that
that's not the case that's why his
defense team was like okay yeah sure
that's cool whatever you want to do like
he he probably doesn't have a lot of
legal liability in that room it's
honestly these tax charges are [__]
dumb too I if I was his legal team and I
was 100 right now I'd be pissed off that
I had to pay this [__] a year ago and
now I have to plea to the [__]
charges [__] you I want my money back
then
it's really something to think about how
Republicans
um don't want to you know comply with a
subpoena or they don't want to uh agree
to show up to court or to the charges or
whatever it is and then you have you
know the son of Joe Biden who is not an
elected official he's not in government
he's a private citizen never has been
he's like yeah okay I'll uh I'll accept
the charges and I will pay the fines and
all that stuff
but on the opposite end you'll never see
Republicans do that they'll fight to the
nail to to object that to never step
foot in court to never even I mean Rudy
Giuliani who just agreed or just
admitted that he had lied today that guy
was playing whack-a-mole he was trying
to avoid authorities to get subpoenaed
on every different charge he had whether
it was the defamation stuff or exactly
trying to get him to subpoena for Gen
six or whatever well that's why that's
why he admitted to lying today because
he doesn't want to give more Discovery
he wants to hide the truth and the only
way to hide the truth that he's trying
to hide for whatever reason that he's
trying to hide it is to tell the truth
about the lie that way that way the
judge is satisfied because that was the
only way the judge was satisfied if Rudy
Giuliani admitted that yeah you were
just [__] lying though at what point
do you think that Lev parnis coming
forward and being like his
when it came to the oversight committee
uh Le Partners has been pretty vocal
recently in the last couple weeks yeah
he's been carrying them look I have a
letter bring me in bring me in and then
he's released some videos and and right
talked more about it so I wonder how
much
was influenced for Rudy Giuliani by
those recent actions that left parnis
took where he was like ah [__] okay he
wasn't he wasn't really saying anything
before now I really got now he's going
like on video now he's like challenging
him I wonder how much of that really is
Rudy Giuliani like part of being like uh
I don't know if I want him it could be
it could also be
look at the chat look at the chat was
frozen frozen
boom boom boom
no I'm not very
that's how I want to be frozen some
weird face that way someone can paint
you mean you want to be like Han Solo or
he's like
yeah so anyways so back to the live
thing in the original I believe you're
much better at Frozen time
um the the um Rudy Giuliani it's
possible that uh DC uh is has him on on
record with grand jury and they're
they're um what they're doing is they
have a deal so in this deal what they
don't want is the crimes leaking out and
if Dre Giuliani gives the discovery in
Georgia of the crimes leaking out it's
possible that it might damage the DC
case with Rooney giuliani's testimony
and him flipping so I I'm not saying
that's the case I'm just saying that I
mean one could think that that Jack
Smith does not want that evidence out in
the open he doesn't want that Discovery
out in the open so he's telling Rudy hey
you better go [__] say you lied to
satisfy this judge if you want to
cooperate in our case because that's the
thing about this whole [__] election
fraud with Trump and his allies is they
committed fraud everywhere like not just
one spot and that only proves that their
their thoughts about centralized
elections isn't even close to the truth
it's not even closed captioning not
available
[Music]
type of of plan that you'd be like ah
you know what huh I don't I want to win
but I don't want to win by a lot like
like a hair and it's like right what do
you why no if you're gonna if you're
gonna go all in and you're gonna you're
gonna overtake the government some deep
State plot to commit voter fraud or
election fraud and say that we actually
determine who the person is even before
these people vote for them and then once
we know the results we make sure that
they really won you're going to tell me
they're like ah you know what we'll get
we'll take the 50. we'll take this well
right no no that's not how it works we
have evidence in authoritarian countries
like Russia when they rig elections they
rig them big because they have to sell
to the masses that this person is
popular right they because they're not
actually popular they have to sell it to
the masses that they are it's a lie it's
a lie essentially so why would you go
for the short lie why wouldn't you go
for the big lie it doesn't ever make any
sense it's like yesterday when I was
saying how they were going after the
Barbie movie and they're like it's a
communist film it's like you're gonna
tell me that this this this this toy
that is rooted in consumerism and
materialism and was just created by a
Hollywood capitalist
firm is a is in a communist plot with
China it's a plastic doll no sense you
[__] idiots you grown men are really
upset about a plastic doll it's
ridiculous but the logic is never never
there well I here here look at this
graphic on Fox News I'm going to show
you the Steve Ducey can't even buy into
the house douchey
um this impeachment inquiry where they
have Hunter Biden on the I don't
understand this like what does Hunter
Biden have to do with the impeachment I
understand that they're like no he he
received money but what does that have
to do with impeachment yeah Hunter Biden
receipt money in a lot of different ways
I haven't seen any evidence no well
listen to Steve Ducey he it's hilarious
we've seen this movie a couple of times
before
First Step impeachment inquiry almost
always it leads to an impeachment I've
heard from members of Congress on the
Republican side they are going to
they're they're going to do the I word
the eye of Joe Biden that guy right
there
uh and they're going to use the 1023
form as the basis for everything here's
the problem uh
the 1023 form makes a damning case
against the bidens but it's completely
unverified and in fact there are certain
critical parts of the story that have
been refuted by the people in the story
so so it it's problematic but and so
that's why Kim McCarthy says we need
other stuff more
oh my God you can't make this [__] up
even Fox News is Steve Deuce he's like
um sounds like a bunch of [__] to me
is what it sounds like to me
I don't know I'm just saying even Steve
Ducey and Fox News is not on this
wavelength
um here's here is uh
let's see I thought I had a damn it
nope I thought I had a Jim Comer clip
was there something Jim Comer said about
this this morning
um I don't know he might have I thought
he did oh here's a good clip speaking of
indictments and and charges um here's a
clip from last night on all in with
Crusades uh jinsaki is filling in but
they're talking about Johnny's you
remember who John Eastman is you
remember yeah he's the guy who planned
the Jan six coup baby yeah he's the well
I mean yeah yeah before that but yeah
you know he's the architect of this yeah
that's kangaroo you know what's funny is
uh I I posted a tweet
um and I don't know it's like in 2021 it
was like um October October of 2021 I
believe and it said
why I said John Eastman is oh right
[__] traitor yeah and then and then I
reposted yesterday with a quote tweet I
said I said what I said about John
Eastman
um I said what I said this was almost
two years ago that I said it but I said
it then I'll say it now but listen to
this it sounds like John Eastman's gonna
get indicted well first let's start with
Mr Eastman we spoke with one of his
lawyers uh this afternoon and he says
they're working on drafting a letter to
prosecutors both in Washington and in
Georgia both did you did you hear that
in Washington
and in Georgia so if you're wondering if
you're wondering that maybe just maybe
Jack Smith and Bonnie Willis are going
to be trying the same exact case you're
probably right now I don't know there's
no there's no
um law that prevents them from doing
that there's normally normally what
happens is the state backs off as they
let the feds prosecute the case
um because it's not Double Jeopardy
there's sovereignty in state and federal
law you can break state law and federal
law at the same time and they can both
charge you it doesn't always happen that
way but it can happen that way but it
feels like to me that John Eastman not
receiving a Target letter knows that
Donald Trump receiving a Target letter
and Johnny's been not going and
testifying in front of these grand
juries makes him a big [__]
Target for indictment here which a lot I
mean John Eastman's got a lot on the
line no one who the [__] John Eastman
was until Johnny Eastman went and told
Donald Trump what he needed to hear to
try to overthrow the government none of
these people
that's the reality too whether you were
in a whether you were a government
official or you were just some random
Joe Schmo uh hack constitutional lawyer
or Professor
um nobody knew who you were and it was
all because Donald Trump not for better
but for worse you know uh because of
Donald Trump he made these people
Infamous they got their name out there
they got their 15 minutes of fame but
now
it's coming back to bite him in the ass
that 15 minutes that 15 minutes was not
worth it I don't think and for him or
Jeffrey Clark but let's listen let's
listen to what the uh the Eastman
attorneys said
okay and that they hope to have this
memo drafted by next week to say the
prosecutor's look he did nothing wrong
he was just a lawyer floating theories
floating ideas on how president Trump
could win the argument and stay in
office there was nothing criminal here
we're not going to cop to any plea and
we hope to get this letter in front of
prosecutors before they make any
charging decision regarding Mr Eastman
no okay I want to go back here just a
second to show you this free frame if
you're if you don't know this is John
Eastman right in this in this weird
[__] trench coat Cowboy look he's got
his little scarf with his Fedora I mean
that looks like the guy's he's wearing
like a what maybe looks like a fuchsia
like a pink like a purple that's pretty
beta dude that's pretty funny yeah I
mean that's Barbie beta at best well
it's Emmy from Southern California isn't
that where he's from or some [__] yeah
he's a professor of like um
[Music]
Professor yeah well there you go he was
the
Chapman University School of Law Chapman
the university is a former unit former
professor and Dean but again it's one of
those things that nobody knew who he was
in the sense of like wow Rudy Giuliani
and Donald Trump knew who the [__] he
was they knew they knew that John
Eastman would come give these theories
and postulate what is possible I didn't
tell him to do it I just told him how to
commit the coup I didn't actually tell
him to commit the coup I just told him
how to commit the coup give me a [__]
break it's called conspiracy you stupid
bastard and the reason why John Eastman
is is uh so has such liability for legal
prosecutor or criminal prosecution here
is because of the the decision from
Judge Carter out of California and
that's the reason why the judge Carter
made that decision because John Eastman
is in California but judge Carter gave
the decision that no there's not
attorney client privilege in these
emails because you were trying to
overthrow an election which is uh what
do you call it rhyme it's a [__]
crime you're not you're not you're not
just postulating ideas you're giving the
president United States who's telling
you I want to overturn the election
you're like well if I were gonna
overturn the election the show I would
do it that's not postulating ideas and
giving him well I think I think he was
like oh yeah floating ideas they're not
floating ideas right they're having a
rally at the ellipse with Ricky Giuliani
with Rudy Giuliani I mean these two
whack jobs I mean look at this this guy
looks like he's trying to sell you some
snake oil which they pretty much did and
Rudy Giuliana is like hey
put that oil in my hair
these are the two people who were more
or less in charge of pushing this idea
onto the public
all of these people who showed up with
weapons
trying to trying to show support for
Trump as he said I will march with you
down and to the capital and to the point
of weapons and to the weapons he said
let them take the weapons they're not
going to use them on me so he knew they
had weapons he knew that well they knew
that because wearing bulletproof vests
right why would you wear a bullproof
vest if not for [__] a congressman was
yeah Jesus Christ a congressman was look
at this okay there's a
look at this gang yeah let me find the
photo there it goes
my internet is [__] up today yeah man
you're you're crazy dude I know I don't
know what the hell's going on today but
here's John Eastman now he's standing on
stage with Rudy Giuliani who was like
trial by combat trial by combat but I
was just postulating ideas I was just
floating him out there it's the same
it's the same tactic whenever someone
gets caught on the Republican party it's
just like the guy who threatened Eric
swalwell was like oh whoa whoa I didn't
actually mean what I said I wasn't
actually threatening him with weapons
right no it's every time they get caught
they get real scared
that they have to but listen pay the
consequences I'm gonna tell you
something
when you when you receive an indictment
from the federal federal government the
doj it it kind of puts a little pee in
your pants I'm not gonna lie it's a
little like whoa wait a second you mean
the highest the highest [__]
organization law enforcement agency in
the world the Department of Justice is
gonna come after me it gets a little
scary not only for your like your
freedom but also for your finances
because it comes I gotta I gotta deal
with something really quick but click
the click the link because this aged so
well okay I'll do this
all right so here is uh here's uh Gabe's
he must have to go take a [__] and
that's probably what it is I'm gonna
imagine that I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding uh maybe I had a knock at his
door here is uh Gabe Sanchez's tweet it
says breaking Rudy Giuliani says he is
quote more than willing to go to jail if
the American people want that nah I bet
look at that I'm [__] this may or may
not be a real graphic I'm just gonna put
that out there it may or may not be a
real graphic
but that's the craziest part is that
these fools uh played this stupid game
where Donald Trump's like oh no no I'm
not actually gonna try to overturn the
government I just want to know how just
in case wink and like what no that's not
how it works you don't get to you don't
get to conspire to commit crime and just
like oh it was just us you know having a
few beers talking about a few ideas no
big deal no you acted on it you acting
all right you went to a list you told
him to go to the Capitol
the law enforcement they said no they
have weapons they have weapons
and Trump said let him do the mags let
him do the mags and when he said let him
through the mags he means the [__]
metal detectors to detect weapons he
said they're not going to use the
weapons on me they're going to use them
on them
what else would he say what else would
he think
what else would this be boy that was a
quick dump I think that was the quickest
[__] I've ever seen in my life God damn
I'm serious oh man what can I say I
really
dropped those kitties off of the pool
you know I had to go God damn bounce to
the Super Bowl you know what I'm saying
I had to go what can I say look I would
not let them stop the steel you know
right I had to count the vote
it was fast you're you're faster at
counting the vote than Arizona for sure
what can I say Carrie Lake you know when
swimming over there you know oh my God
so they're having another stupid [__]
hearing this morning and weaponization
hearing or whatever the hell this is and
I don't know I don't know and I don't
even know if I want to play Clips
because it's so dumb I mean we got to do
this stupid dance every [__] week
about how ridiculous they are and how
many breaks they step on you know what
let's show this video because this is a
crazy video for me oh I watched it this
morning that's nuts for New York this is
crazy that's crazy for all the people
this doesn't have to do with politics
um but I want to show you this video
this is nuts this is uh in New York City
I believe this is like down where Hell's
Kitchen is or something
it's during rush hour but you see this
this is a this is a crane on top of this
building there I don't know if they're
building a re reconditioning this
building or what they're doing I think
it's a it's a brand new building it's a
brand new building that they're building
um but you see the smoke here so there's
a like a fire up on this crane
um at the top where you know and they
use the crane to pull materials up to
build the building higher and higher and
higher higher
um but watch this watch this thing it
falls where from where the fire is it
seems to disconnect but watch this
oh [__]
damn
[Music]
son of a [__]
I mean luckily it looks like the fire
department was there
and you see the fire is still going
there so I don't know exactly what
happened but it it goes across the the
way there the the airway to in the other
building kind of Clips the other
building on the top of the building and
then crashes to the street I don't know
did they say anyone was injured or
killed and it's kind of crazy that if
there was no one injured or or killed in
this and this gets injured when NYC
crane collapses in the building after
catching fire
yes so the crane caught fire up on the
top 41st and 10th in Manhattan oh so it
is in Manhattan yeah at least five so it
sounds like uh six at least six people
have been injured
um
but I mean luckily I would say at the
moment that things fell you know it
looks like there's fire trucks and
people in the area so they were clearing
the area
um to avoid any further damage I mean I
can imagine how that would I mean
obviously the fire started and then the
the authorities were called to come deal
with it and then the collapse happened
so at that time everyone's trying to get
out it sounds like and
luckily it wasn't worse than it was or
it could be you know this is one of
those things where it feels like in a
movie when I think it's like the movie
Eagle Eye with Shia LaBeouf and uh
and I'm blinking on her name but anyway
about artificial intelligence and the
government and there's like tracking and
that movie there's a scene where he's in
the FBI's FBI office in Chicago and they
sweep this crane across so he can escape
you know and
that's what that almost remind you like
it reminded me of something out of a
movie where it's like something comes
crashing through a window someone's like
in an office like oh [__] you know and
they're like right around the way
but it does look like it's from it does
look like it's from a movie to be quite
honest speaking of movies
the Barbie the Barbie movie um uh
critics the writing credits can't say do
I have to throw Nick Fuentes in here too
oh my God you still are you still
working on it are you still working on
it uh yeah I haven't filmed it yet I did
some stuff I went to dinner last night
you know I told you this morning you
better uh you better get your indictment
what was that uh Ray because
if it feels I don't know if I get a
feeling that that dude's gonna get
indicted I just I don't know I just have
that stench I'm going to show you a clip
here later that gives me that gives me
the evidence that yes in fact he is
going to be indicted and he is guilty
and totally I'll show it to you but here
is um here's here's Nick Fuentes the uh
the Nazi
um you know people for years I call them
Nazis are like easy easy on the Nazi
talk and then this guy came to the
Forefront we showed him on the show a
lot and most people didn't know the [__]
he was when we were showing him on the
show like who is this guy like this guy
is who is sending the talking points up
the ladder to the GOP this is like where
Ron DeSantis and some of these others
[__] get their inspiration from what
do you think Rhonda Santos works with
neo-nazis because of this fool right
here but listen to his review this is
Nick fuent and I'm sure it's just
riveting and I'm sure it has you know no
misogyny in it whatsoever I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding uh let's listen
to his review for a Barbie I love the
tears to be quiet honest I wanted a fun
Beach Movie I wanted dance numbers I
wanted the beach I wanted pink I wanted
shopping that's what I would want out of
a Barbie movie I wanted Whimsy I wanted
Whimsy I wanted fantasy I wanted a
Fantastical Whimsical light-hearted
Beach story instead I got this who's
Afraid of Virginia Woolf Jewish
deconstruction
always always always with the [__]
anti-Semitism you could always count on
Nick man he's he's always a Nazi first
right I mean it's got to be you can't be
[__] second right his [__] is called
America first but really should be
called Nazi first yeah
oh my God he could no he has to be Nazi
first that's the way that he runs
absolutely there's uh why did that just
make me think of was it Barbie I'm
trying to remember what it was making me
think of Barbie I don't know but he's
he's talking about he's talking about
how he wanted he obviously went and
watched it so here's another case of
these [__] idiots giving their money
to to the studios and to the theaters
into the movie
it's not what I wanted Nick Fuentes who
has been caught watching
um transporn on his web browser before
what really wanted it to be about pink
and beaches and parties pretty beta dude
right it does what I tell you man I was
like their their Viewpoint just just
wait they're going to adopt being gay as
okay they did I'm telling you what I'm
telling you Nazis Nazis explain this
okay okay all right so if you look at
and how Trends have happened within
conservative groups and liberal groups
at one point
conservative like I was talking about
yesterday conservatives would say oh no
skinny jeans metrosexual very very bad
very bad right very very
ugly disgusting no no that's looks gay
looks gay why would I ever do that I
want my carpenter pants and my boots
okay right and flannel shirts
what have you seen happen right there
was the beard phase that you know that
was also maintained
no I'm not insane
beards were something that I would say
if you know you you manscaped them you
maintained them at one point that was
considered metrosexual because you were
caring right so I'm a Metro because I am
not saying you're Metro I'm just saying
you have good hygiene if you're caring
about your beer okay but these are
things that the right these
conservatives say oh no this is [__]
up you can't do this stuff it's super
okay it looks gay it's ax gay all the
stuff right
beards skinny jeans pink other colors
these are all things that they once
thought were super gay or whatever right
and they've begun to adopt them okay
they're in their own groups right
they're gonna get to I mean dude they
wrestle around in these man these these
uh red light tanning for their balls and
wrestling around naked type of stuff you
know
that's super cool at any point and
they're gonna be like no no that's just
like manliness that's manhood I'm
bonding with it why why why is anything
masculine why is it inherently straight
I don't understand why they think that
no idea no idea but what I am have you
seen have you seen a lot of gay dudes
they have some of the best [__]
bodies that you can find yeah
like they they look more manly than you
could ever dream of straight Tucker
Carlson who looks like a little twig
that any fit gay dude could pop in half
get the [__] out of here man but why why
does that you if you look at all of
these things that have happened clothing
appearance some hygiene I know that a
lot of them don't really care for
Hygiene but some hygiene
does Nick does he looks like he smells
like a bucket full of mothballs I'm not
gonna lie probably he looks like he's
wearing his Grandpa's suits that he
stole from his grandmother yeah yeah but
you've got these other guys who are
muscular men rolling around wrestling
naked tanning their balls in front of
you where are you watching this where
are you working Carlson dude Tucker
Carlson did a whole segment on it he did
an hour-long and I missed the gate
wrestling them naked gay wrestling oh
you didn't see it that was in the set
that was that was in this side anyway so
you have to remember that all of these
things that were once uh super gay or
they were like not conservative or not
not you know not what God intended they
have begun to adopt these things slowly
over time and that includes wearing
you know pink fuchsia purple all these
things that might at one point been
feminine and so he just said he wanted
pink he just said he wanted I know and
people like Matt Gates wore pink that is
true and you know I'm just saying when
it comes to this I think they're slowly
going to adopt they may you not say it
outright like gay is okay to be gay but
they might be like oh yeah I yeah what I
had sex with a man what's so wrong about
that
I can see it happening I can see it
happening where they slowly adopt this
do you think do you think it's because
they realize that Their audience
is is a bunch of closeted in cells and
that's the way just just like they're
hiding they're terrified of their
sexuality they're not secure in their
manly hood they're not secure that I'm I
can be gay and be a man type thing and
then a guy Carrie points out on Facebook
gay is fun yes it is what how the hell
do you think we get all these crazy
things that we've got some of the most
creative coolest things are gay as [__]
and that's and that's the great part
about culture is that you don't you
don't have to be a certain sexual
orientation to appreciate other people's
Creations that are of another sexual
orientation like just wait they're gonna
say they're gonna say oh you don't you
don't bond with your fellow brother
naked in bed it's pretty gay dude whoa
that's what they're gonna say oh so
you're saying so you're saying because
you don't do it uh-huh that's because
you don't do these things that may
appear to be homosexual because let me
tell you something when I was never
going to say it outright they're never
going to say like oh this is uh or like
this is gay or I'm gay or whatever right
right they're gonna do these things you
don't do them then that's gay they're
exactly
their appropriate gay culture is what
you're saying they're going to
appropriate those things that they have
have in the past and right now right
have con uh condemned to say this is
against what God wanted this is this
someone's gonna find some way some
excuse to be like it's not actually
you're not gay or that's not gay by me
doing it it's just me being innately
male alpha male I'm getting in touch
with my brother I guarantee they're
slowly going to adopt this and then if
you say oh we'll just come out as gay
but I'm not [__] gay bro why you say
that
they're going to be very offended by
that but they will do the things like
yeah man I [__] suck a dick I had sex
with a guy whatever it is they're gonna
say all those things they're gonna do it
and if you don't do it
then you're gay uh Jalen says
Randy rainbows so much gay fun yes I
love I love Randy but I can't play his
videos here he's he is a [__]
about his copyright uh oh yeah seriously
now I I gotta pick the ones that I want
to show and we show them yeah he's a
mother about his guy well she should be
he spends a lot of money and a lot of
time in a lot of effort on his content
so he should protect it if he wants but
let's talk about this jacket in cells
these in cells are gonna do you're doing
it behind closed doors they just haven't
they openly said it yet but when they do
just wait I'm telling you well let's
let's finish up what Nick thinks here
about Barbie
with the uh you know 31 Flavors of uh
diversity
it was it was poo I didn't like it two
thumbs down [__] you
movie sucked
[Music]
oh man what a great I mean he just
objectively did not do anything to
convince anyone that they shouldn't
watch Barbie there like nothing it is
it's horrible what a horrible review I'm
reviewing your review Nick and it sucked
it's Pooh [__] you it sucked
what a [__] what a [__] I mean
it's not it's not surprising though it's
not surprising coming from these [__]
fools that they that they hate that they
hate Barbie
um I promised you to play a clip of why
I think Donald Trump
is a totally totally guilty but first
off we played this guy the other day
Aaron Thompson on the show this guy is
yeah this guy's [__] nuts man this
guy's [__] crazy he's probably gay
too well I'm gonna show you this clip
whoo boy this is gonna get underneath
your skin but um I'm telling you this is
where like you're saying man this is
where right wing this is where
Christianity is going they can't they I
think you're right maybe because they
can't stop focusing on other people's
sections there's no reason like you
other people's genitals you have to you
yes I've said it before right like
whether it's you know kind of their own
suppressed or repressed feelings of
of how they want to be
but are fearful of the party they're in
being being unaccepting to their way of
life their their desires whatever it is
and because they can't be them true
selves there's this constant like
umbrella or like blanket of hate that's
over them the self-hate but also hate
towards others who are able to live the
lifestyle and do the things that they
want to do that they can't right and and
these people are going to use that hate
against other people and justify it by
the word of God and all this and all
that
but I honestly believe their their
Obsession their gross Obsession they're
disgusting obsession with uh Little
Children their genitalia wanting to
inspect it when you're not even a
medical professional wanting to
determine who can go in which bathroom
versus others like all of these things
are weird
um fights to be be going after right
that's a it's a weird Hill to die on and
the fact that they are dedicating all of
their time and effort to doing so
I think is just complete projection of
their own wanted desires I think you're
right well here's the thing here's the
thing I'll go even deeper mm-hmm
the reason why and we watched the clip
from not Aaron Thompson but a guy at the
same church the other day he was talking
about how oh this person these people
just hide this they hide this stuff they
hide this stuff what truly is at the
heart of this and you're going to listen
to Aaron just be vile here
um but you gotta listen to this stuff
you can't you can't hide away from it
this is [__] that exists and people are
like Nick Fuentes and his followers are
listening to garbage like this from a
Pulpit and here's the thing is I believe
that some of these folks
are absolutely 100 homosexual they know
it they know they're gay they don't want
to admit it in their culture and they
don't want to admit it to themselves
they don't want to admit it out in the
open and they also they're pedophiles
they're pedophiles they're gay history
that's been proven to be true and and
the other the other thing the other
thing that I think they think is the
reason why I have these thoughts about
pedophilia is because I'm gay which is
not the case that those are two separate
things right your sexual orientation has
nothing to do with you weirdly liking
children in that way but I think they
think it has to do so they project it
because they're fighting their own
demons inside of them right they're
finding their own demons and this is oh
it's a it's a daily battle when they
talk about fighting demons on others
they're fighting they're talking about
themselves their own demons exactly and
that's I think that's how deep it goes
but listen I don't take it from me
listen to Aaron in his own word words
when Joe Biden is holding like some
lgbtq plus AI whatever you want to call
it
um have this big thing at the White
House and he's like I support trans kids
there's no such thing as trans kids
it's groomers telling them that they're
trans there's no such thing as that
okay groomer telling people that there's
no such thing as trans kids I just want
to what's his name Aaron Thompson Aaron
Thompson is his name we should probably
do a uh
they should do they definitely should
check his electronic devices I'm sure
but let's continue what this guy says
about children he's talking about
children here remember this it just
isn't true
show me all the trans kids from the last
6 000 years oh my God oh my God okay so
so I I'm he's gonna round it out here
with some real intelligence he thinks
that they're just invented listen you're
not gonna find them because you know
what homos weren't allowed to adopt
people back then right that's a new
thing
what so here's what he's saying here's
what he's saying is that all trans
children are children of what he says is
homosexuals because they're allowed to
be adopted so somehow in his mind all
trans kids because there's not any
really but all trans kids that claim to
be transglids are adopted and they're
adopted by members of the lgbtq
community which is wildly not even close
to being the truth I'm not even like not
that I mean I don't even understand and
but the thing is is that all the people
sitting there are all biased to this
information right of course they all
it's an echo chamber and and what looks
like the conference room of a [__]
Marriott right right and there's
probably six people six dudes uh who
forced three of their wives to come
listen to this idiot well you got it you
gotta love how they don't show the
audience like it's when when I see
videos of Nick Adams doing some [__]
alpha male prep speech in the back room
where there's a bunch of cake gigs of a
bar and like yeah yeah and then you you
hear like three dudes go yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like look
either you're adding audio in there or
you do have deranged
brainwashed people who don't I mean can
you imagine can you imagine yeah I'll
form can you imagine having that much
hate like taking taking a Bible
reading it interpreting it to say that
God doesn't love anyone who isn't a man
or a woman biologically
and saying that I now have so much so
much hate towards another person
who might be different than me
or who is different than me or whatever
it might be
then now I have to use all of my time
and my energy and my effort to make sure
that that person feels like they don't
ever exist and they've never existed
like to have that much hate but don't
you think that Aaron Thompson here
because here here's here's the tweet
that it came from because they call him
a Christian hate preacher because that's
exactly what it is
um but don't you think Aaron Thompson
here has some demons that he's dealing
with about trans when he's saying it
doesn't exist it doesn't it's it's
almost like he's he's trying to convince
himself
not trying to convince the people in the
room he's trying to convince himself
that this stuff doesn't exist he also
might be trying to convince himself that
anything he might have done right that
might be seen as gay or homosexual as he
said or whatever it is
uh he's trying to justify to be like
well no it's not actually that I'm not
I'm not actually gay I don't have those
desires right exactly why I mean and
that's that's the that's the true story
here and you know what a lot of people
are going to hate that we would say that
but I don't give two [__] because I'm
getting sick and tired of these people
hating on a group of people who has
nothing to do with them nothing no
desire to do anything I
but I'm sure any one of the LGBT
community wouldn't have want to have one
[__] thing to do with Aaron Thompson
and even be in the same room as that guy
so why in the [__] would he give so much
a [__] about them if they don't even
want to be in the same room as him and
the reason why is because he's dealing
with his own demons these people like
Nick like Aaron Thompson like all these
[__] idiots are dealing with their
own demons just like this guy's dealing
with a shitload of demons totally
totally dealing with a bunch of demons
the eternal struggle in the fight that
he's happening on an everyday basis God
oh my God this is how much money do you
think he spends
on having yes men around him
oh people that are just like licking his
balls I I mean the entire fortune that
he doesn't probably have
is probably probably he probably
promised them just like he did well not
I'll give you more than just the diet
coke job if you follow me tomorrow logo
and say yes right exactly right I'll let
you change my shitty diaper
it says it's just an upgrade it's an
upgrade carry me into Diet Coke change
my diaper I mean it's an upgrade you
know that sort of thing well listen to
this is [__] this is great this is
proof that he's guilty as [__] and he
knows it
president Trump are you concerned about
your own people testifying before the
special counsel thank you very much
we're innocent we're totally innocent do
you see how he said that you see how he
said that we're totally and oh totally
man oh I've got breaking news by the way
do you really you give it to me it looks
like it looks like the hunter Biden plea
deal is on hold again
[Laughter]
that's great I don't I don't know
uh it's in Delaware I'm not sure who the
judge is now now the judge taking the
plea deal you have to understand the
judge taking appointed by Donald Trump
so the Dead the judge taking the plea
deal
um will be a different judge than the
one who sentenced him yeah so Justin
hearing ends with Hunter Biden plea deal
on hold U.S District Judge Mary Ellen
Noriega said she was not ready to accept
the plea deal and the hearing ended with
Hunter Biden pleading not guilty for the
time being the judge asked the size to
file additional briefs explaining the
plea Deal's legal structuring
so I don't know we have a cannon
situation up in Delaware it says judge
yeah judge says gun deal for Hunter
Biden is quote unquote unusual U.S
District Judge Marianne Noriega called
the deal Federal Prosecutor's reach with
Hunter Biden for his gun possession
offense unusual I this is something I
don't understand if they'd come to an
agreement and they're like yeah he's
going to plead guilty the judge can be
like oh actually you know what on second
thought she said the deal in which Biden
would enter the diversion program to
resolve the charge contains some
non-standard terms such as broad
immunity from other potential charges we
don't usually make diversion agreements
public the judge said referring to the
move by the parties to make the aspect
of their agreement public and discuss it
in open court
okay well here's here's what normally
happens here's let me tell you what
happens because I know from experience
okay is that when when you're taking a
plea deal there is a there is a public
plea deal that the judge can and or
sometimes will read in The Plea hearing
and then there is a cop deal normally
which has the details of which that the
government the prosecutors and the
defendant do not want out in the open
and that's part of the agreement is that
there's a sealed agreement and an
unsealed agreement normally and normally
it's because there's other actors
co-conspirators involved a lot of times
a lot of times the government if you're
going to take a plea deal they don't
want to damage you publicly especially
in this case where Hunter Biden will be
damaged publicly because uh manga will
just [__] go ape [__] if they get a
certain amount of unsealed records okay
so there is a seal and an unsealed um
plea deal as it were now what happens is
the judge in this case the magistrate
will in this case is a trump judge
um will
and Minister the plea deal with the
defendant and the prosecutors right so
this hearing is to say the judge says
okay prosecutors you agree this deal yes
defendant you agree this deal yes you
understand the deal yep every part about
it they told it you went over it you
understand it that's what you want to do
is you want to plea yes okay great
we're gonna plea to this deal you're
gonna plead and then they stand up and
plea guilty these charges what is
happening it sounds like in the
courtroom
is that either the judge doesn't hear
the agreement or there's not a real
agreement here on what they're doing and
my guess is because it's a trump judge
and she's acting kind of like Canon
because the judge has the ability to
torch this thing they're the federal
judge they're they're presiding over
there the judge does not have to accept
this deal they do not the judge can say
no this is a horrible deal I don't like
this deal go back and do something
different they can't they're the [__]
federal judge so in this case the judge
is probably [__] footing around to
create this news I would guess just like
Canon was producing certain aspects of
the documents case to produce certain
dues for Donald Trump to produce certain
narratives it would be my guess and it's
her right to do it that's why when we're
selecting presidents who appoint federal
judges we should be careful who we
select so it also says uh nor noreica
Noriega whatever uh quiz the lawyers
about the terms of the gun charge
concerned that the Judiciary would not
Norm only oversee such an agreement she
also expressed concern that the
agreement on the tax charges did not
give her the ability to reject or modify
the deal so it looks like she's
uh having concern with everything not
just the gun charge she can only act on
the gun charge and not act on the tax
charge that that's how or the tax
charges that are happening it says early
in the hearing norik asked if there were
more serious charges that could still be
brought prosecutors and Hunter Biden's
lawyer both said they were not again
they're playing this game with the House
Republicans the House Republicans even
filed a memorandum which does not happen
in a case that they have no involvement
in other than they hate Hunter Biden and
they want to spread lines about Hunter
Biden but it was rejected in court their
memorandum was even rejected in court
that they have nothing to do but it may
be influencing the judge in her decision
to to go back and forth on this stupid
[__] plea deal so just watch just
wait I'm telling you there's going to be
rakes that these people are going to
step on because there's a legal process
that is right before your eyes it's not
hard to see it's exactly what it is now
is there a trump judge maybe trying to
throw [__] against the wall to see what
sticks of course there is I mean yeah
that's gonna happen and and they're like
oh the Trump indictments are all
political it's all political it's all
because of politics yeah okay all right
then why is the House of Representatives
sending them in a random to a sentencing
judge who is going to sentence to a guy
who's pleading guilty to tax crimes in
which he's wait Tony are you saying that
that sounds like the weaponization of
the federal government doesn't sound
like the weaponization of government
this guy is saying we're innocent we're
totally innocent and the narrator as you
say says he he isn't he is
he is they he is they him they him I
guess I don't know who we is I don't
know
many people are saying I know what he's
doing you are innocent I know what he's
doing yeah it's Maga well I know what
he's doing no I know what he's doing
okay is we the people who committed
crimes are innocent and then eventually
he's gonna go whoa what me commit crimes
it was John Eastman it was that
[__] he gave me the idea he's
the one that came up with the idea for
the crime that's what he's doing when he
says we he's like it would be
interesting to see that back and forth
and just like throw out and be like look
if you can point us to anyone
anyone else if you can identify someone
else who did something wrong here we
will toss away the charge and then see
how quick he's like all right look so
there's Rudy Giuliani John Eastman
there's also this guy uh Mark Meadows
there's also this is this this this this
this like I'm sure he would run through
the list easily he's like all right you
already they already they already
chatted with you okay go to the next
person they already chatted with you
okay we'll go to the next person and
that's a good point that's a good point
because the point is that's why they
work from the bottom up so that doesn't
happen they go they go for the small
fish to get the big fish that's
literally what they tell you literally
they're like look you're a small fish in
a big pond there's bigger fish than you
and we want to fry them and you can lead
us to the big fish if you know what I'm
saying they literally say that type of
[__] to you listen
Donald Trump is the big fish that Jack
Smith is going after Donald Trump is
probably not going to get a deal unless
it's the last resort for Donald Trump
here he is going to be indicted he will
have God knows how many hundreds of
felonies by time we get to DC with the
January 6th case Georgia who knows where
else it could be Arizona it could be
Michigan where he's going to be charged
no one can tell we already got 16 fake
electors that are charged in Michigan a
fake Trump electors
uh to try to overturn the Michigan
election so no telling how many charges
this guy's going to have and we're going
to cover it here on the Tony Michaels
podcast every single weekday I know not
this Friday I know I know we we just
don't have Friday covered but here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna do bone
head of the week and I'm gonna show you
someone was asking in the chat where you
vote on YouTube
um for the money of the week they were
asking where the community tab is at so
I'm gonna show it to you I'm gonna show
it to you real quick on the website
rarefast see if you go to if you go to
YouTube here it is here it is here's the
YouTube channel ah there's the YouTube
channel if you pan down if you go to the
tabs here at the top it says home video
short slide podcast playlist Community
there's the community tab
um so you'll see you'll see all kinds of
memes that we post there there's one of
Greg Abbott and then there's one about
Jason Aldean
um here's the hunter Biden card there's
there's a Barbie meme but there's
there's the poll there's the last week's
poll so go to YouTube and if you're on
YouTube right now go ahead and subscribe
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and like button as you're leaving
because you can vote for bone and the
week on the community tab you can also
vote on Twitter I'm not calling it X
[__] him not until he's always gonna be
Twitter not until he gets that not until
now the image the image of the Twitter
sign being half taken down I think is a
perfect representation for the company
right it's it's half-assed it looks like
it's falling apart it looks like it's
it's like dilapidated it's been
abandoned there's no one really keeping
things on running anymore poor maybe
somebody shows up in the morning and if
there's someone there at night I mean
that'd be a good day but I really think
like the image of them having the uh
where because the two at Twitter with
the Twitter logo the bird Larry the bird
was on the sign and so they still have
the bolts in place where it was raised
off right so half of it is gone
and half of it is still there it just
looks like they're like ah man it's like
clear clearance sale and we're like
we're just leaving town that's great
that's great Elon you don't disappoint
so go vote for bone end of the Week
Tonight Tonight you're gonna vote for
Monet because we're gonna do tomorrow
when Thursday we're gonna do bone of the
week on Thursday because we won't be
here on Friday I'm very apologize but we
won't be here on Friday so make sure to
look for the bone of the week pulled
tonight on Twitter and on YouTube also
you want to download every single
episode on Apple's Spotify and Google
and you can watch us on Facebook too at
the Tony Michaels if you still got a
Facebook account you can follow us on
Twitch for free go to twitch.tv Tony
Michaels also remember if you have
linked your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account don't forget to
re-subscribe we've had a few people
re-subscribe here uh for several months
in a row yes today already so don't
forget to resubscribe if you've linked
your Amazon Prime account with your
Twitch account
hell boy I know there'll be more news on
the hunter Biden how many times you
think they're gonna they're they're
gonna have a false alarm here before
they finally get the money shot of him
actually pleading guilty in in the court
you think it's gonna happen today huh I
don't know because they've already left
so I don't know if they'll come back
today yeah it'll probably be next week
we'll probably you think it'll happen do
you think it'll happen before or after
Trump gets indicted you know what you
know what that's exactly what this is
that's exactly what they're [__] all
over they're trying to make sure that
that the indictment is uh exactly 100 I
don't know they're [__] ignorant
they're [__] ignorant and we're gonna
cover their ignorance right here on the
Tony Michaels podcast same time same
place tomorrow serve sup [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
foreign